that seems more polite hi guys it's time
for strip of consciousness Monday I
decided to shoot this video in the
bathroom because of streams I loved my
life on a confused edge another great
thing about this is the audio quality of
the echo I'm in New York City and I have
been for a past couple days doing some
super cute business meeting single beep
beep plus I'm shooting this video in
front of window and people are walking
by so back to my old self great hair to
the box okay that one wasn't planned how
are you guys doing it good huh Green
great day what's going on in the world
of life of things Jeff I ate a burger
today that's yes
picked up a few tricks up in here but he
caught someone what do you call the
sunbather that what do you call an
irrelevant charming sunbather a pan gent
yeah girl you just watch that from the
street figure it out
I've seen a homeless lady doctor pants
on the street in New York City this is
not like that okay I can't Dakota I
might have had a few cocktails in my
system and I might have just been
hanging out sitting in my bed or every
service cuz that's my favorite thing to
do when I travel and I got into a cave
all watching all of your camp Takota
review videos on YouTube you guys are
just great is this recording I'm so
happy that you like the film some of
them made me and get a little like like
when they yell onions do you guys just
saw a bunch of onions making you guys
are just a bunch of onions I hope that
if you haven't already ordered
you have to call it up please go on
either iTunes or Kim's phone calm and
order it oh there's an episode of Graces
faces last Friday make sure you go check
it out I'm exploring Jen and Andrea
jennxpenn a native a russets rooms and I
put on an ill-fitting onesie not
ill-fitting in a big way no fitna
eunetta the crotch got some action that
day I'm taller than they are turns out
okay I need to leave because I'm
supposed to go to the airport now
fans we are dude friend gonna get on two
sides of the car because we don't want
to seem luck with that close
well there's a child whoa whoa look down
hands and pants look down hands and
pants are dude friends
oh my god my arm touch her dear I'm dude
I'm gonna walk further away from you
hands and our jeans put her hands on
your jeans always were chosen to do